برنارد شاربونو
لوضعها
ركبتيها أنسا أملو هداس ماتت في
كل 20 كيلوغراما من القات يبتسم عطا
عطر جورت بولبول دانا الدنماركي
طلقات
قضت أساسا على طريق الهجرة
2015 15 حتى تمر عبر تركيا
اليونان ايطاليا فرنسا قليلا في
سويسرا لأنها مضطرة للذهاب إلى الأمم المتحدة
في ألمانيا في بلجيكا ثم هي
سيصلون إلى كاليه والرأس
إلى المملكة المتحدة
بعد ستة أشهر من الفراغ على الواجهة
وأراد أن يجد والدته وهذا
حزين بعض الشيء لكني جئت
هنا لرؤيتها
خاصة في ملودة على اليسار في
يحمي ضياء أو القاتلين
الممولين لكن مشاة البحرية يبطلون
مخططات فرنسا لديها
عمل نعترف أننا نرتديه
مشروع فني لذا فهو كبير
سلسلة أصدقاء أمل التي تم بناؤها
مثل هذين في
التحضير أخذوا هرمهم
أخبرني
كان
متزوج من ابنته كم